Hello and welcome to the second video on Construction Script.
In this video we'll be looking at building on the scattered tool we've already made
in order to use a line trace so that we can query the environment
and we can then add the static mesh component in line with the ground.
So here I am back in the engine. I'm going to open up my scattered tool again.
I'm back here on the Construction Script because we're still working on the Construction Script at this point.
Now I'm going to want to keep the for loop.
That is absolutely fine so I will move that over to the left hand side.
However, before I add the static mesh component, I'm going to want to do something called a line trace.
So I'm going to drag out and I'm going to search for line trace.
And you can see here we have line trace by channel.
So I'll just add this in between the two sections.
And what a line trace is going to do is it's going to draw a line between the start vector and the end vector down here.
And then it's going to return any data on any collisions that it hits on the visibility channel.
And we can get the data out of this out hit here.
Now all we're going to need to do is calculate the start and the end location.
I'm going to do that by coming over here and grabbing my random unit vector multiplied by radius.
And I'm going to press Ctrl and X to cut that out.
And then I'll come back over this side and press Ctrl and V.
Now this is great for giving us the X and the Y, but I'm going to manually want to make the Z.
So I'm going to do that by dragging off the X and I'm going to type make vector.
So that's going to do the opposite of splitting a vector.
It's going to put together a vector.
This time I can just leave the Z out.
So we're forcing Z to be zero.
So up to this point we've been working in relative space.
So that means we've only had to calculate the transform from the root of our actor.
However, when we do a line trace, this will be done in world space.
So I'm going to need to calculate the world locations where we start from and where we end at.
In order to calculate the world transform from the relative transform,
all I need to do is take the relative and then add on the actor's location to that.
So I'm going to get the actor location.
I'll type in actor location and here's get actor location.
And then I'm going to add these two together, drag off, push add.
And connect them up.
So this is now going to give me the world location of this.
Now, because I'm drawing a line, we're going to want to have a start and end position of this.
However, I'm starting with a singular vector.
So the start position, I would ideally like to be above the actor that we're working on.
And the end position, I would like to be below.
So when you place the actor, it's going to look above it and draw a line directly down below the ground.
So I'm going to do that by dragging off this and pushing plus and selecting add.
And then I'm going to add 400 on the Z axis.
And that will give me my start location.
Now I'm going to do the opposite here.
I'm going to subtract.
So I'm going to subtract 400 on the Z axis.
And that will give us our end.
Now I'm going to disconnect by holding down alt and left clicking everything after this line trace.
And for the draw debug, I'm going to select for duration.
This is just so I can demonstrate how it will work in the engine.
So if I hit compile and then jump back into the engine, you can now see we just have a lot of red lines.
So if I was to grab this cube, move it here and then move our actor.
We can see a lot of red lines except for under the cube where it's green.
So if I would shift this, every one of the line traces, you're going from 400 above and it's attempting to go 400 below.
If I'd shift the camera, you can see it here.
So for every line, it is going to return us the data of where the red squares are here.
And that's great.
So if I was to go back to my scatter tool, I'm going to turn off the draw debug so that none.
And I'm going to come over to our add static mesh component.
Now I am only going to want to add a static mesh component if the line traces actually hit something.
So the way I'm going to do that is I'm going to hold down the B key and left click.
That's going to create me a branch.
And I'm going to connect the return value to the condition.
So that means this code will only continue down the true path if we've actually hit something.
OK, so now we have to add in the static mesh location.
To do that, I'm going to right click on the transform and select recombined struct pins.
And that's going to give me a yellow input.
And now if you look at the line trace by channel, you can see that we have one blue out hit pin.
Now this is a struct.
So if I right click on that and select split struct pin, we're going to see that we get a lot more options.
The one that we want in this instance is the out hit location.
Now I can't connect that directly in.
That's because, as we mentioned before, line trace is in world space and the static mesh component is going to be relative to the root of the actor.
So in order to fix this, what I'm going to have to do is drag off the out hit location.
And then I'm going to search for subtract.
And plug that into the relative transform location.
And then I'm going to get the actor location.
So what I'm effectively doing is minusing the actor's location from the out hit location to give us the relative transform.
And now if we jump back into the world, you can see that this is all conforming to the ground below it.
So if I increase the radius to about 600 and the spawn amount, let's say 400.
Now you can see how that has just distributed and placed meshes on the ground around it.
OK, so thank you for watching.
In the next video, we're going to add some more functionality to the scatter tool.
We're going to make it so that with a button push, we can bake out all of these static mesh components to actors in their own rights.